nos dicen que queremos factorizar la
siguiente expresión que tienen aquí y
nos dicen podemos factorizar la
expresión como un v al cuadrado donde y
v pueden ser enteros constantes o
expresiones de una sola variable cuales
son u y v y también nos piden factorizar
la expresión pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo muy bien veamos esta
primera donde dicen que podemos
factorizar la expresión como un más v al
cuadrado como podemos tener esta
expresión en términos de un v al
cuadrado una forma es recordar a qué se
refieren un más v al cuadrado y más v al
cuadrado es el cuadrado de un binomio
que ya hemos visto en muchos vídeos esto
es igual a un cuadrado más 2 veces el
producto de estos dos términos 21 v más
v cuadrada si nunca han visto esto antes
o no están seguros de dónde viene esto
los invito a que vean esos primeros
videos en donde explicamos esto
pero esto coincide con el patrón podemos
expresar este término como cuadrada pues
si esto es un cuadrada entonces tiene
que ser igual a x 7
de hecho permítanme ser un poco más
cuidadosa podemos expresar todo esto de
acá como un cuadrada si cuadrada es
igual a x + 7 al cuadrado entonces es
igual a x + 7 y esto de acá tiene que
ser v cuadrada si esto es v cuadrada
entonces v es igual a ye cuadrada porque
ye cuadrada al cuadrado es ya la cuarta
así que v es ya al cuadrado ya nos
dijeron que esto puede factorizar se
como una sube al cuadrado pero vamos a
asegurarnos de que sea correcto
este término de enmedio es realmente
igual a 2 por 1 por v veamos dos por es
2 x x 7 por b es porque cuadrada que es
exactamente lo que tenemos acá dos por
de cuadrada por x 7 por lo que esta
expresión que se veía algo complicada
con este patrón de aquí por lo que
podemos verlo como una sube al cuadrado
donde v es igual a equis 7 y v es igual
a ye cuadrada ahora podemos usar esto
para factorizar la expresión podemos
escribir que esto es igual a 1 más v al
cuadrado y ya sabemos a que son iguales
v toda esta expresión es igual a que es
x 7 que pongo en paréntesis para que se
vea más claramente más v más cuadrada al
cuadrado que es exactamente lo que
escribimos por acá y no es necesario que
escriba en estos paréntesis pueden
escribirlo directamente como x + 7 más
ya cuadrada al cuadrado hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nuevamente nos dicen
queremos factorizar la siguiente
expresión y nos dicen que podemos
factorizar la expresión como un más v
por un menos v donde y v pueden ser
enteros constantes o expresiones de una
sola variable pausa en el vídeo y traten
de encontrar
y también traten de factorizar la
expresión bueno vamos a recordar a que
es igual en general una sube por un
menos v bueno si esto no les parece
familiar los invito a que vean los
vídeos sobre las diferencias de
cuadrados cuando multiplicamos todo esto
nos dará una diferencia de cuadrados al
cuadrado menos v al cuadrado si se toman
el tiempo para hacer esta multiplicación
se darán cuenta de que los términos de
enmedio se cancelan por lo que quedan
lado cuadrada - la ub cuadrada esto
coincide con este patrón pues para que
esto sea cuadrada y esto sea v cuadrada
quiere decir que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de esto que es 2x noten que un
cuadrado será 2 x al cuadrado que es 4 x
cuadrada y v tendrá que ser igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 9 y a la sexta la raíz
cuadrada de 9 estrés y la raíz cuadrada
de a laxe
es la tercera potencia ahora podemos
usar esto para factorizar la expresión
porque podemos decir que esto de aquí es
igual a un cuadrada menos v cuadrada por
lo que podemos factorizar lo como un más
v por un menos v a que será igual esto
más v es igual a 2 x + 3g a la tercera
potencia y un menos v es igual a 2x
menos 3 y a la tercera potencia aquí lo
tenemos ya factor izamos la expresión
que tendríamos que haber escrito aquí
pero lo hicimos aquí arriba y terminamos